[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE WILLIAMS: A matrix diagram is
a tool used to arrange and display
information in order to help you
understand important relationships
and make decisions.
It can be used in a
number of different ways
to help you make decisions for action.
For example, imagine you're
looking at a list of change ideas.
You know you have only so much capacity.
And you want to be thoughtful
about where to start.
You might use a matrix
diagram like this.
Let's draw this out.
So what I can do here is basically
say, OK, I've got my different ideas.
And with my team, I can
look and say, well, gosh,
let me think about
this here for a second.
So with Idea 1, on a scale
of one to five, how much
do we think this can be done
in, say, a 90 day time frame?
We might look at that and
say, oh, gosh, I can only
do-- this may take longer than 90 days.
I'm not sure, so maybe
I'll give that one a two.
On Idea 2, though, I think this one
totally could get done in 90 days.
And Idea 3, there's
probably a high likelihood.
OK.
Great.
Well, let me think about
will to fix this problem?
Is this important to people?
I might come here and say, well,
you know there's a lot of will
here for an Idea 1.
There's actually quite a bit for Idea 2.
But Idea 3, you know,
it's something that people
aren't ready to work on yet.
And then as I look at things that
I have control to make changes on,
I might come across and say, OK, great.
This again, maybe it's moderate
level to control the changes.
This one, pretty much
completely in my control.
And Idea 3 is not in my control at all.
And then sponsorship, I
look and Idea 1, there's
a sponsor who says that this would
make sense and they'll look at it.
There's good sponsorship for Idea 2.
And there's limited sponsorship,
moderate sponsorship for Idea 3.
So as I'm looking at my matrix,
now I can kind of look at my data
and say, well, which of these ideas
has the best chance of success, right?
And in this particular
case, as I look across them,
I might decide to select Idea 2, because
I've got a higher degree of belief
that it's going to be able to be
accomplished in a short amount of time,
there's will to improve it, I have the
ability or the control to test changes,
and there's good sponsorship.
So that's a high spot for me to
potentially be successful in a project.
As you go through the
ranking, you hopefully
discover that one change
idea may be better
than another to start
with because it possesses
more of the factors for success.
It also can help you
think about where work
may need to occur to improve the
likelihood of success of other change
ideas before you begin to test them.
Can you think of where in your project
a matrix diagram could be useful?